hello and welcome to this video I took
it took ages to get a game and it's
actually pretty busy on the server and
playing song with 1800 rating that's
really rare 1848 mean by rating is not
exactly high at the moment but still a
bit of a mismatch so let's see what
happens we have them exchange ruin oh
that looks risky giving me the evening
of the light squares um so what can I do
I can take simply on we r oq one lady
that also looks quite quite good yeah
this isn't that problem next development
this XO is non-existent really now I'm
not be taking be seven and after FTC
five I have Queen h5 check which is also
quite a serious issue now that looks
very problematic ok so how to do this
even is six make some sense but can also
take on the phone like going to be 30
that's the same Bishop e3 we might play
but that it's also better for white
let's do it I thought I thought Queen to
d5 but I can take on d5 take on default
on advantage Queen trade is not ideal
since you want to keep the Queen's
normally but
it'sit's better so why not if it takes
me five again I go clean edge five okay
let's take this Queen be true I I don't
know okay I don't think that can work so
94 looks normal here can also insert
Luke to be one yep maybe insert this
movie ok and now yeah probably look see
one kick the Queen around queen to d3
there is Luke checks b7 now text b7 he
takes you one notch we can go here and
now I don't know p 7s hanging
so I think be 79 for 366
and the equator at five looks quite good
threatening 27 mate and the rope
so yeah 96 yes does the trick for luke t
7 may track and this is radar doesn't
make any sense yeah he'd simply um yeah
refuse to develop but the way to
describe it in one sentence yeah I think
here this is already very risky because
but you don't want to give up the bishop
and the only motivation is to wreck the
pawn but this is just far too risky the
position opens up too quickly look you
want this and Bishop e3 immediately have
the computer wants to do this
immediately but if I've should be also
good it should be kind of any comparable
Wow the computer wants to go for this
generation and this there are maybe at
least the King might be somewhat Savyon
created this yeah and a quick assault on
various why am I not better in this
position does then I because he takes d5
I sorry F takes d5 all that stupid I
didn't didn't see this one correctly
well hit like is fine so it was better
to take and just develop him okay he
played this one and this is just looking
too far too risky and 94 also strong but
yeah you're not going to survive check
survive this sister gently this would
have been the end of the game yeah black
practice
did not develop I think it's best only
if you're in this position here to do to
develop something we should be six maybe
or yeah something like this should at
the end gift like chances to equalize I
don't like this line so much for
blackness f6b should be four but it's a
matter of days there are many good
players and theoreticians who actually
do like it Jim so it's a bit of a bit of
a taste of thing ok guys thanks for
watching